hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 7 video so many
awesome fights in this episode probably
because the director was their fight
coordinator this is also the last
episode for the big Vandal Savage
crossover episode that's happening in
two weeks I'll talk about that at the
end of the video just careful for
spoilers from episode 7 if you haven't
seen it yet in the the reverse flash
ring giveaway is new again this week all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video starting with number 5 Diggle uses
the arrow of o Beal for another creative
takedown of one of the ghosts this is so
much fun so opening action sequence
great just the beginning of an entire
episode full of awesome fight sequences
big choreographed fight sequences the
director of the episode James Bamford is
their fight coordinator he's one of the
best fight coordinators in Vancouver so
of course anytime they do stuff like
this it looks awesome but the best
takedown was Diggle
using the arrow mobile to like crash
into frame and take out one of those
ghosts if you remember that's the exact
same way Felicity took down ravager at
the end of season 2 now the whole point
of that scene was just to let you know
that hive is trying to destabilize the
government in the area the federal
government was sending in money to
strengthen the banks the ghost just blew
it up they don't want the city to get
any financial assistance from the
federal government and that also kind of
ties in with this running plotline
across the first half of the season
damian darhk-- preparing the city for
his associates from hive to get here
which i think is vandal savage's who
he's talking about
but on the number for damian darhk--
meets Oliver Queen at the campaign
fundraiser so I couldn't stop thinking
about whether or not damian darhk--
actually knows Oliver is the green arrow
and I think as of their first
conversation in the episode he did not
but I think by the end of the episode he
was putting the pieces together
he's a smart man you can see the wheels
turning in his head it's kind of like
the flash season 2 watching paddy slowly
put the pieces together she's probably
gonna figure out that Barry's the flash
eventually damian darhk-- gonna put the
pieces together that Oliver is the Green
Arrow the same person who will never
stop fighting him but on the number 4
diggle's brother is still alive so they
infiltrate damien darhk's facility
wolfmann biologics which is actually a
reference to Marv Wolfman who's a
longtime DC writer he even wrote crisis
on Infinite Earths you can't throw a
rock in the DC universe without hitting
something that Marv
Wolfman is touched at some point but the
unmasked Andy and it's not a trick it's
not a clone it's the actual andy damian
darhk-- has just co-opted him so Diggle
and Oliver get into it again over what
the right course of action is Diggle is
pissed that Oliver wants to pull a
season 3 plan just like he did with
Rachel Ghul
Oliver his initial idea is to cozy up
with damian darhk-- take him down from
the inside he goes like dude you did
that last year it went terribly do not
do it again Oliver on the other side of
the coin is telling Diggle not to give
up on his brother he deserves the
benefit of the doubt and by the end they
both come around Oliver takes damian
darhk-- on in the light of day and
Diggle tries to help his brother the
interesting thing about that is there
are consequences diggle's brothers like
yeah I did all that terrible stuff I'm a
terrible person in damian darhk-- is
obviously going to retaliate against
oliver so doing the right thing won't
necessarily lead to a good outcome but
onto my number two WTF Thea also thinks
that she has a better way a better way
than killing she's gonna try and embrace
this darkness inside her to take down
damian darhk-- something about the state
of her soul backfired against damian
darhk-- when he tried to lay hands on
her so she's like okay I'm gonna try and
use this but his intrigued as Merlyn
looks here this is obviously not going
to end well but raise your hand if you
thought that she was actually gonna go
after that pedophile
the minute that Merlyn offered that
solution I was like wow they are really
laying it on thick they wanted to seem
like she has a real choice to make like
this is the worst human being you could
possibly imagine he doesn't deserve to
live and he really doesn't deserve to
live but he has a good person she's not
going to actively campaign for murdering
people if he didn't catch it either
damian darhk-- also joked and called her
princess Meredith there's just a brave
reference because of the red and the
arrows and finally on to my number one
WTF mayor Oliver Queen vs damian darhk--
I'm just gonna go ahead and call him
mayor now I feel like we all think that
Oliver's gonna win his campaign but his
Damien's looking at him there at the end
of the episode you just get the sense
that he is going to retaliate hard in
the next episode like the next episode
of arrow is the second part of the big
legends of tomorrow crossover now that's
like The Collected two-hour episode
that's going to introduce Vandal Savage
I do feel like he's going to be a part
of hive but I do think there are other
people that are in hive that will show
up it's kind of like Hydra it's a very
complex or
organization damian darhk-- Vandal
Savage aren't the only people you're
gonna see with any authority but what's
gonna happen is is the story will start
on the flesh we'll learn more about
hawkman and hawkgirl that will cross
over with Vandal Savage
- arrow that episode isn't gonna air for
two weeks that's right next week is
gonna be a break I mean I was also do
bonus videos and stuff like that but
there's no new episode next week of the
flash or arrow no need to freak out
because the cast is going to heroes and
villains fan fest so there's any videos
to be made for stuff that comes out of
that I'll totally do that - they said
they're gonna be doing some fun stuff I
don't know what that is they haven't
announced like they have some special
surprise but all in all I felt like it
was a good episode I don't think it teed
up things quite as much as last week's
episode of the flash like it seemed like
they were seating more big things
there's been a little bit more
mysterious with the reveals that it's
made well we got to see the atom again
he really just reminded us that hey I'll
be around to help but I'm not coming
back full-time that's what all that
Palmer Tech Talk was with felicity he
did have a pretty badass
save during that last big fight I
actually thought it was the flash for a
minute when he zoomed in super quick as
I wait what was that but I think the
best character moment was when Diggle
showed up all of it was like hey you
know about time he showed up and he was
like my brother needed me the green one
such a great bro moment and it just
shows you that Oliver is every bit
diggle's brother as Andy is like you
have your blood relatives then you have
the family that you choose and the whole
question of what would you do to protect
your families is a big theme across the
flash and arrow this season like you
have Irish trying to fix her family you
have all this stuff with Laurel trying
to fix her family Oliver trying to fix
his family and fix his family of the
city like the city is literally his
family but my next video will be for
that full arrow trailer I was waiting to
see if they'd post new footage the promo
that they aired after arrow was just the
exact same footage they did after the
flash so I'll do a video for that
explain what's going on with Hawkman and
Hawkgirl because they're tying their
backstory to Vandal Savage like Vandal
Savage comes after Hawkgirl like that's
the reason he comes into the story so
I'll explain what's going on with that
it's a little bit different from the
comics but they're taking a lot of
classic Hawkman Hawkgirl stories and
tying it in with Justice Society stuff
it is gonna be awesome
and don't forget jessica jones drops on
friday i'll be doing a whole bunch of
videos for that for those that are
asking about Supergirl this week I am
planning on
a new video I just don't know which day
it's gonna come on so you can just
follow me on Twitter and Facebook for
updates on when videos are posting
especially with Jessica Jones stuff
happening so while you guys wait for all
that stuff to drop you can click here
for last night's episode of the flash
and you can click here to catch up on
agency show from last night to they did
they did some really cool Captain
America Red Skull stuff so you guys got
to check it out
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow